here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was the movie that
inspires how I live my life every day is
actor Paul Giamatti said Rudy Jeff
Goldblum said lean on me ma Nia Trump
said the Shawshank Redemption yeah
first by head when I am not at home I
can most often be found Tom Hanks said
on the set Ke$ha said in the recording
studio Steven Tyler said in the
nightmares of children poor guy I spent
my youth
I spent my youth protesting against thee
Martin Sheen said Vietnam War
Jenna Elfman said Iraq war Larry King
said Trojan War
that's right he's very very old very if
Trump runs in 2020 he'll need Orrin
Hatch said help from the Republican
establishment Wolf Blitzer said to get
his approval rating up Vladimir Putin
said my permission when I heard Michael
Flynn pled guilty the FBI I immediately
congressman Adam Schiff said wondered
who was next James Comey said felt
somewhat vindicated Mike Pence said
began choosing my vice president America
America must commit itself to finding a
renewable source of Anderson Cooper said
energy bill Gates said energy Chris
Christie said natella I'm always worried
I'm disappointing Jake Gyllenhaal said
my critics Anna Kendrick said my fans
Larry King said the grim reaper
it's it's not right yeah not right it's
not right it's not right he's a
wonderful man he's a good guy he's no
man all right here we go I spend most of
my day trying to figure out how to john
mccain said passed legislation Al Gore
said raise awareness about the
environment Mitch McConnell said turned
the poor into an industrial paste of
some kind
my parents were disappointed because
they wanted me to become Amy Schumer
said a lawyer Harlan Williams said an
accountant dr. Phil said a doctor
all you have to do to do a dr. Phil
who's go out was in phony and then go
it's that simple do it at home or at a
party you want to do it at a party and
finally when I heard that George HW Bush
was the oldest living president US
history I thought Tim Allen said he
deserves a long happy life Jake Tapper
said I hope he lives to be a hundred
Jimmy Carter said oh it's on [ __ ]
[Applause]
you